A GOOD NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT"."
HOLY SMOKES.
WHAT DID WE LEARN LAST NIGHT AT
THE DEBATE?
AMERICA DESERVES BETTER EMMA
THAT’S THE FIRST AND MOST
OBVIOUS THING WE LEARNED, ALL
KINDS OF PEOPLE SAID THAT TODAY
AND THEY WERE RIGHT.
THIS IS A GREAT COUNTRY, MOST
DECENT PEOPLE IN THE WORLD LIVE
HERE, WE OUGHT TO BE PROUD OF
THE FACT THAT WE ARE AMERICANS,
PART OF OUR CULTURE AND PART OF
OUR HISTORY.
MOST OF US WANTED TO CONTINUE,
WE WANT TO THE NATION OUR
GRANDCHILDREN IN HARWICH TO BE
AS STABLE AND HAPPY AS THE
COUNTRY WE GREW UP IN BUT LAST
NIGHT’S DEBATE GIVE US A LITTLE
CONFIDENCE THAT WOULD HAPPEN.
IT WAS A PAINFUL, HIGHLY
DEPRESSING 90 MINUTES AND AT
TIMES THINGS SEEMED OUT OF
CONTROL.
YOU SAW IT, YOU KNOW WHAT IT WAS
LIKE.
AS A POLITICAL MATTER, THE MAIN
THING WE LEARNED LAST NIGHT AS
IT WAS A MISTAKE TO SPEND SO
MUCH TIME FOCUSING ON
JOE BIDEN’S MENTAL DECLINE -- HE
IS FADING, WE SHOWED YOU DOZENS
OF EXAMPLES OF IT FOR MONTHS NOW
BUT ON STAGE LAST NIGHT, BIDEN
DID NOT SEEM SENILE.
IF YOU TUNED IN EXPECTING HIM TO
FORGET HIS OWN NAME AND WE DID
EXPECT THAT, YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
SURPRISED BY HOW PRECISE SOME OF
HIS ANSWERS WERE, NOT ALL OF
THEM, BUT ENOUGH OF THEM.
TRUMP ISN’T GOING TO WIN THIS
RACE BY CALLING JOE BIDEN
SENILE, NOR IS JOE BIDEN GOING
TO WIN BY CALLING HIM A RACIST,
IT DIDN’T WORK FOUR YEARS AGO,
IT WON’T WORK NOW, PERSONAL
ATTACKS RARELY DETERMINE
OUTCOMES.
WHAT MATTERS, ALWAYS, TO VOTERS
ANYWAY IS WHAT YOU DO, NOT WHAT
YOU SAY.
RIGHT NOW, MANY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE SOMEONE DEFEND THE COUNTRY.
AMERICA HAS NEVER BEEN UNDER
FIERCER ATTACK THAN IT IS NOW,
VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE ATTACKERS
COME FROM THE DOMESTIC LEFT.
THEY ARE DEMOCRATS, BIDEN
VOTERS.
"I AM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY" AND
JOE BIDEN REMINDED US LAST
NIGHT -- IT’S TRUE, IT SHOULD BE
ENOUGH TO KEEP TRUMP IN OFFICE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS BECOME
MORE RADICAL THAN ANY MAJOR
PARTY IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY, THE LEADERS PLAN TO
DISMANTLE THE SYSTEM OUR
FOUNDERS STARTED CENTURIES AGO.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO AWAY WITH
THAT, THEY WANT TO ABOLISH THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE, THEY ARE
TRYING TO END TRADITIONAL
ELECTION DAY VOTING.
THEY INTEND TO INVALIDATE THE
FILIBUSTER, GUARANTEE PERMANENT
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE BY ADMITTING D.C. AND
PUERTO RICO INTO THE UNION, WE
WILL HAVE 52 STATES AND
DEMOCRATS WILL BE IN CHARGE
FOREVER.
THAT IS THEIR PLAN, WE AREN’T
MAKING IT UP, THEY HAVE SAID IT.
SCARIEST OF ALL, THEY ARE
PLANNING TO HIJACK THE
SUPREME COURT BY EXPANDING THE
NUMBER OF JUSTICES.
LEADING DEMOCRATS HAVE ENDORSED
THIS IDEA -- IT’S NOT A SMALL
CHANGE, IT WOULD END THE THIRD
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
THE JUDICIARY WOULD CEASE
DISPENSING JUSTICE, IT WOULD
INSTEAD BECOME AN INSURMOUNTABLE
PARTISAN POWER POLITICS WIELDED
EXCLUSIVELY ON BEHALF OF ONE
PARTY.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO LIVE IN A
COUNTRY LIKE THAT?
IT’S HORRIFYING.
JOE BIDEN WAS ASKED ABOUT THIS
LAST NIGHT, HERE’S HOW IT WENT.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO TELL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TONIGHT WHETHER
OR NOT YOU WILL SUPPORT EITHER
ENDING THE FILIBUSTER OR PACKING
THE COURT?
>> WHATEVER POSITION I TAKE IN
THAT, THAT WILL BECOME THE
ISSUE -- THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SHOULD SPEAK, YOU SHOULD GO OUT
AND VOTE.
YOUR BOATING NOW, VOTE AND LET
YOUR SENATORS KNOW HOW STRONG
YOU WILL FEEL.
VOTE NO.
NOW.
I’M NOT GOOD ANSWER THE
QUESTION --
>> THE RADICAL LEFT --
WILL YOU SHUT UP, MAN?
>> Tucker: NOBODY FORCED BIDEN
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION, A KEY
QUESTION, THAT WAS FRUSTRATING
TO WATCH.
IF IT WAS ALSO EASY TO INTERPRET
WHAT HE MEANT, OF COURSE
JOE BIDEN PLANS TO PACK THE
SUPREME COURT, OTHERWISE HE
WOULD HAVE DENIED IT.
COURT PACKING IS NOT POPULAR
WITH THE PUBLIC, NEARLY 70% OF
AMERICANS OPPOSE IT, THAT
INCLUDES MORE THAN HALF OF ALL
REGISTERED DEMOCRATS BUT THE
EXTREMISTS WHO NOW RUN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE DEMANDING
IT AND JOE BIDEN WILL FOLLOW
THEIR LEAD.
THAT’S WHAT RADICALISM LOOKS
LIKE, ANY THING THAT STANDS
BETWEEN YOU AND THE POWER YOU
SEEK TO DESTROY, EVEN IF IT’S
THE WORLD’S OLDEST
CONSTITUTIONAL COURT WHICH OUR
SUPREME COURT IS.
WE SHOULD BE AFRAID OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE WILLING TO DO THINGS
LIKE THAT BUT IN JOE BIDEN’S
CASE WE DON’T SEEM TO BE AFRAID
AND THAT LEADS TO SOMETHING ELSE
THAT WE LEARNED LAST NIGHT AT
THE DEBATE.
TONE IS EVERYTHING.
BIDEN ALL BUT ADMITTED ON STAGE
THAT HE PLANS TO TEAR DOWN OUR
SYSTEM, BUT HE DID IT IN A CALM
THIS IS YOUR CAPTAIN SPEAKING
VOICE.
HE SEEMED REASSURING EVEN AS HE
HINTED AT REVOLUTION.
DONALD TRUMP BY CONTRAST
DEFENDED OUR SYSTEM, THE SYSTEM
THAT MOST PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY
SUPPORT.
NOTHING TRUMP SAID ON STAGE WAS
RADICAL, VIRTUALLY NOTHING HE
EVER SAYS IS RADICAL COMPARED TO
PUBLIC OPINION POLLING ON THE
ISSUES.
IT’S HIS TONE THAT RATTLES
PEOPLE.
TRUMP COULD MAKE A WINE LIST
SOUND MENACING.
SO IN THE END, AMAZINGLY,
TRAGICALLY, MANY PEOPLE WATCHED
LAST NIGHT CONCLUDED THAT
JOE BIDEN IS THE STABLE, STEADY
ALTERNATIVE.
THEY CONCLUDED THIS EVEN AS
JOE BIDEN SUGGESTED HE PLANS TO
CHANGE THEIR LIVES, THEIR
COUNTRY, PERMANENTLY AND FOREVER
IN WAYS THEY WON’T LIKE.
IT’S QUITE A TRICK.
THE ILLUSION OF REASONABLENESS,
BARACK OBAMA WAS A MASTER OF
THIS.
BIDEN LEARNED WELL AND SO HE
CONTINUED LAST NIGHT.
WATCH JOE BIDEN EXPLAINED THAT
ACTUALLY, HE’S THE AMERICA FIRST
CANDIDATE.
>> IT WOULD CREATE AN ADDITIONAL
$1 TRILLION IN ECONOMIC GROWTH
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE ABOUT BUYING
AMERICAN.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SPENDS
$600 BILLION HERE ON EVERYTHING
FROM SHIPS TO STEAL THE
BUILDINGS AND THE LIKE.
UNDER MY PROPOSAL, WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY PENNY OF THAT
HAS TO BE MADE BY A COMPANY --
>> Tucker: WE’VE GOT TO BUY
AMERICAN, BUY AMERICAN SAYS THE
MAN WHO WELCOMED CHINA INTO THE
WTO AND HAS BEEN SUCKING UP
ASSIDUOUSLY TO ITS LEADERS EVER
SINCE.
FIGHT THE BILLIONAIRES, SAYS THE
MAN WHOSE CAMPAIGN IS FUNDED BY
OLIGARCHS ON WALL STREET AND
SILICON VALLEY.
JOE BIDEN STOLE DONALD TRUMP’S
LINES, IT WAS REMARKABLE.
HOW WAS BIDEN ABLE TO DO THAT?
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN SHOULD
RUMINATE ON THAT QUESTION.
TRUMP’S ADVISORS AND IN-LAWS ARE
TELLING HIM TO BRAG ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE HE HAS LET OUT
OF PRISON, THIS AT A TIME WHEN
OUR CRIME RATE IS EXPLODING AND
PEOPLE ARE DYING AS A RESULT OF
IT.
JOE BIDEN’S ADVISORS PLAN TO
LIFT MANY MORE PEOPLE OUT OF
PRISON BUT THEY AREN’T BRAGGING
ABOUT IT ON STAGE, THEY ARE
HIDING IT.
THEY USED TO DEBATE TO TALK UP A
BUY AMERICA PROGRAM THEY WILL
NEVER IMPLEMENT.
WHAT WE’VE LEARNED HERE IS THE
BIDEN PEOPLE ARE VERY SERIOUS
ABOUT POLITICS.
THEY KNOW WHAT TO THE PUBLIC
WANTS, EVEN IF THEY PLAN TO
IGNORE IT IF THEY ARE ELECTED.
OF COURSE THEY ARE WILLING TO
SAY ANYTHING, THAT HELPS.
WE LEARNED THAT WHITE SUPREMACY
IS THE SINGLE GREATEST THREAT TO
OUR COUNTRY, HOW COULD THAT BE
YOU ASK?
IT TURNS OUT THAT MOBS OF WHITE
SUPREMACISTS JUST BURNED DOWN
MINNEAPOLIS AND KENOSHA, THEY
SHOT COPS AND WITH ALL, THEY
TORCHED WENDY’S, THEY DESTROYED
PUBLIC MONUMENTS IN ATLANTA AND
SAN FRANCISCO, THEY DEFACED WAR
MEMORIALS IN WASHINGTON, THEY
LOOTED MACY’S IN MIDTOWN CHICAGO
CHICAGO.
ALSO IN THE CITY OF CHICAGO,
WHITE SUPREMACIST MURDERED
HUNDREDS OF AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN
EVERY WHERE THEY WENT, THESE
RIGHT WING BIGOTS SPRAY-PAINTED
RACIST GRAFFITI AND THREATEN THE
SLEEPING CITIZENS IN THEIR
HOMES.
THE WHITE SUPREMACIST DID THIS,
THOSE PROUD BOYS.
IT WASN’T JUST FACTUALLY UNTRUE,
IT WAS INSANE.
CRAZIER THAN ANY CONSPIRACY THAT
GOOGLE HAS EVER BANNED, YET THEY
ARE NOW DEMANDING THAT YOU
BELIEVE IT AND IF YOU DON’T
BELIEVE IT, THEY ARE GOING TO
PUNISH YOU.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THAT?
THAT’S A GOOD QUESTION, IT’S
ALSO AN OMINOUS SIGN.